Okay, let's start with the Android Operating System. The Android
system, heavily based on the generation and handling of events,
so it is mostly an event driven system. However, it
also has some elements of publish, subscribe, in the way
elements in the system can register for elements of interest.
So we can mark both styles here. So what about
Skype? We haven't discussed Skype yet. So here we probably
had to take a little bit of a wild guess.
But as we will see in more detail in the
rest of the lesson. Skype is mainly a peer to
peer architecture, with some minimal elements of a client server
architecture. For example, when you start Skype and sign in
to a conceptually centralized server. So let's move to the
World Wide Web. As we just discussed, the Word Wide
Web is based on a rest architecture. And because rest
style, is a hybrid derived from other architectural styles, including the
client server architectural styles. Both of those styles apply here.
And finally Dropbox is by and large, a client server
architecture. As conceptually, we upload our documents to a Dropbox
central server, and get the files from the same server.